TUCKER?
>> Tucker: SEEMS THAT WAY.
TRACE GALLAGHER, THANKS A LOT
FOR THAT.
WE HAVE A FORMER SECRET SERVICE
AGENT.
DAN, I'M A LITTLE BIT CONFUSED.
CNN CALLS ITSELF A NEWS NETWORK.
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN MEDIA
REPORTER.
THEY HAVE SAID VIRTUALLY NOTHING
ABOUT THIS ON THE AIR.
WHY AREN'T THEY COVERING THIS, I
WONDER?
>> THEY'RE INCREDIBLE, RIGHT,
HOW THE INTENSITY OF THE
COVERAGE SEEMS TO HAVE LAPSED
DRAMATICALLY.
I WAS READING A PIECE EARLIER
TODAY THAT IN THE FIRST DAY OF
THIS, OR TWO DAYS OF THIS, THERE
WERE 43 MINUTES OF COVERAGE.
>> USING THAT LOWER THIRD OF THE
SCREEN, THINGS LIKE BIGOTRY AND
HARASSMENT ON THE -- ON BEHALF
OF THESE KIDS AND TAUNTING ON
BEHALF OF THESE KIDS.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS THE
NETWORK -- REMEMBER THEIR THING?
THEY HAD THAT VIRAL AD.
THIS IS AN APPLE.
YOU CAN CALL IT A BANANA, BUT
IT'S NOT AN APPLE WHEN CNN
BECOMES THE FOCUS OF THEIR OWN
TERRIBLE COVERAGE.
>> Tucker: IS IT ETHICAL TO NOT
REPORT ON YOUR OWN ROLE IN A
MAJOR NEWS STORY, THIS LAWSUIT?
>> NO, OF COURSE NOT.
I MEAN, LISTEN ON THE OPINION
SIDE, DO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
THOSE ARE OPINION SHOWS AND
THEY'RE BASED ON PEOPLE'S
OPINION.
BUT IF YOU'RE CLAIMING TO BE A
NEWS NETWORK -- THAT'S WHY I
BROUGHT UP CNN'S AD THAT THIS IS
AN APPLE.
WE'RE A JOURNALISM NETWORK.
WE GET THE FACTS RIGHT.
IN JOURNALISM -- I CAN'T SAY
THIS ENOUGH.
YOU HAVE ONE JOB IN JOURNALISM.
ONE JOB.
TO PUT OUT THE FACTS.
IT'S THE PUBLIC'S JOB TO THEN
FORM AN OPINION BASED ON AN
ACCURATE STATEMENT OF FACTS.
CNN IS PROCLAIMING ON THEIR NEWS
SIDE THAT THEY HAVE THE FACTS IN
THIS CASE TUCKER WHEN THEY
DIDN'T.
THEY -- AS A MATTER OF FACT,
THEY HAD THE ENTIRE STORY
BACKWARDS.
COMPLETELY BACKWARDS.
NO, IT IS NOT ETHICAL.
THEY SHOULD DO THE RIGHT THING
AND GIVE THE SAME INTENSITY OF
COVERAGE TO THEIR SCREW-UP AS
THEY DID INITIALLY TO THE STORY
ABOUT SANDMAN WHICH WAS
INACCURATE.
>> Tucker: RIGHT, I MEAN,
THEY'RE DISHONEST, SO WE
SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED.
WE'RE NOT -- THEY SLANDERED THE
GUY, OBVIOUSLY.
ALL OF THESE KIDS, THEY CALLED
THEM RACIST, THEY
MISCHARACTERIZED THE NATIVE
AMERICAN ACTIVIST.
WHY DIDN'T THEY JUST APOLOGIZE
FOR IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S SOME --
WELL, YOU KNOW, I'M KIND OF
LAUGHING BECAUSE YOU'RE OPENING
SEGMENT TODAY, BY THE WAY, WAS
AWESOME ABOUT RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
THIS IS THE SAME NETWORK WHO
WHEN I WORK OUT IN THE GYM, IT'S
THE ONLY TV IN THE GYM.
ONLY TV IN THE WHOLE GYM.
IT'S THE ONLY TIME I SEE CNN.
IT'S AN ALL DAY, HYPERBOLIC FEST
ABOUT A FICTITIOUS HOAX CALLED
COLLUSION.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE RIGHT.